gotcha you thought I was animatronic hi
guys it is Thursday you're on its grace
which means it is tipsy Thursday so
we're calling it I can't remember any of
the things I went on my tumblr and I
asked you what did you want to learn how
to do today and someone said fall on my
face and get up without embarrassing
myself I fall all the time constantly my
body is covered in bruises because I'm
so clumsy so I've come up with ten
different ways that you can fall and get
up ish without embarrassing yourself in
public here they are fake narcolepsy
it's okay Goosen narcoleptic and
everyone else in this public space oh
that's where the floor went Oh goose ass
for the floor hunt that's where the
floor went got it doesn't mean rope on
to do it you're here now
I meant to yoga that no yep quick down
dog just a quick down bone in
I'm better than you I thought it was on
fire cuz I thought I was on fire I
thought I was on fatties
there was a PE we've all been there
blame the floor one
watch out for that normal cycle blame a
stranger why did you push me goose why
did you push me you missed it but she
pushed me pretend you're doing a social
experiment for your school
today's social experiment where school
to see who would help me Oh only that
dog we're all bad people game show
you're all on a hidden-camera show I
pranked you so good you're welcome
yeah you're welcome I bet you all feel
better about yourselves now
there you go there ten ways to fall and
get up in a public space without totally
embarrassing yourself hope this helps
cuz I don't know
now you're just getting it cuz you gotta
move
how embarrassing